c'est un des rendez vous de l'été tous
les jeudis soirs jusqu'au 26 août un
film est projeté au grand parc de la
coulée verte à elancourt un cinéma en
plein air organisée par la commanderie
gratuit accessible à tous dans la limite
des 1000 places disponibles une manière
de partager un moment convivial en
famille ou entre amis c'est
effectivement l'occasion de redécouvrir
ou de découvrir des films on aurait
peut-être vu que sur petit écran
et là on a quand même la possibilité de
les voir sur d'un écran de 16 mètres de
large et est aussi des films qu'on a
peut-être vu nous plus jeune et qu'on a
envie de faire découvrir aux enfants par
exemple
cette année encore la programmation est
variée de quoi plaire à petit et grand
vous pourrez par exemple rire devant la
comédie de wes anderson the grande
budapest hôtel le 15 juillet prochain à
22h vous êtes superbe tarder je vous
assure je ne sais pas quelle crème ils
vous sont appliqués à la morgue mais je
veux la paix c'est la bonne nouvelle de
cette troisième édition un film
d'animation du réalisateur japonais
miyazaki est projeté le 5 août à 21h il
s'agit du château ambulant jusque là cet
animé était interdit de diffusion cinéma
de plein air c'est donc une joie de
pouvoir le diffuser pour l'organisatrice
là c'est vraiment se laisser porter au
rêve après chacun y verra ce qu'il a
envie à la fin de cette histoire et
surtout aussi dans ce film c'est quoi on
y revient on y revient dans sa tête
après et on retrouve des clés et surtout
c'est se laisser porter dans ce
magnifique univers oniriques de gnac
fillon semblait pas plus bas à sophie je
ne veux plus fuir j'en ai plus qu'assez
de fuir
j'ai enfin trouvé quelqu'un à protéger
toi
pour terminer l'été un grand classique
du cinéma vous est proposé il s'agit des
goonies de steven spielberg et chris
columbus un film de 1985 à voir ou
revoir alors chérie je suis dans la
salle de l'ancien phare à jouer je vais
vous signez les morte comme votre
dernière blague avec toutes ces petites
créatures qui se multipliaient quand on
l'arrêté de lotir c'est ça
[Musique]